[Music]
are you hiring actors to play wrestlers
or are we the wrestlers no what were the
oddest jobs you guys have had in real
life I did work as a clown for
children's birthday parties and
characters I would like to note I also
did Snow White and Cinderella and Oliver
yeah I did I'm definitely more of a snow
white than a Cinderella but and I made
balloon animals and I painted faces and
I did songs with the kids it was a
really dynamic job oh how much time do
you have I once handed out pepcid ac
packets as samples outside the Penn
Station in New York to make a couple
extra dollars you're not familiar with
pepcid ac it is an anti-diarrheal yeah
what is this come on let's go
I was a parking ticket er in college I
used a ticket okay oh that's such a
heartless I did take it people I did not
like on purpose I'm lame I don't have
any like like I was a barista an
assistant I mean I once watched my
entire like barista inventory being
eaten by a bear in Alaska that was like
as crazy as a god but I mean your job
wasn't crazy but that's a crazy yeah he
really liked to come to mint they that
was a terrible waiter I terrible just
what made you terrible I was in a great
server and then I moved to the line like
you know in the back of the kitchen
because I do I worked in restaurants
demoted no no I wanted to be a line guy
and then I didn't really know how to do
that and I didn't realize the intensity
so that was also embarrassing I was
pretty good grill cook you know that was
just on the back for a part of that job
it's weird being a comic and being in
show business when it's not working out
and you get older you start thinking
like well I could always what go back to
the restaurant you know be like let's go
back to that line dude I could flip some
eggs